merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sénateurs les républicains du
Val-de-Marne président de la commission
des affaires à troncs étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées du Sénat on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Julien Lecuyer
de la Voix du Nord bonjour monsieur
avec vous Christian Cambon le président
de la radar ukrainienne était au Sénat
hier 20 ans qu'un président de Parlement
étranger ne s'était pas exprimé dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat ses scaraplé Gérard
Larcher il y avait besoin de ressouder
les liens entre l'Ukraine et la France
et ça aussi le symbole de cette visite
il y avait plusieurs symboles me
semble-t-il il y avait le fait que le
président de la Rada était reçu comme le
président Larcher lui-même a été reçu à
la radar lorsqu'il est parti à Kiev et
il avait eu aussi ce privilège en tant
de guerre et dans des conditions assez
terribles de s'exprimer devant les
parlementaires
ukrainiens et je pense que c'était assez
normal que à la faveur de cette visite
le président stevenchoux soit entendu
par le Sénat je crois que ça a été un
moment très fort mais ce Cambron le
président de la radar oslane Stéphane
chou qui a évoqué avec des mots assez
durs une un conflit une confrontation
civilisationnelle je reprends ces termes
avec la Russie c'est cela cette guerre
une confrontation
civileisationnelle je pense
effectivement que nous en sommes arrivés
là
si l'on reprend les choses au départ
déjà les revendications de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine n'était pas recevable
lorsqu'on prétendait qu'il y avait 44
millions de nazis en Ukraine ça ne
tenait pas la route un seul instant et
je crois effectivement maintenant que
c'est le choc de deux civilisations et
singulièrement
organisé par la Russie qui considère que
c'est déjà un combat contre le temps et
contre les valeurs occidentales en
vérité qu'est-ce que Monsieur Poutine
reprochait à l'Ukraine c'est que ce pays
il se tournait vers l'Europe et voulait
vivre avec les valeurs européennes que
nous connaissons des valeurs de liberté
de démocratie ça c'est insupportable
parce que si le le régime russe se
confrontait aux règles démocratiques qui
sont les nôtres il y a fort à parier
qu'il y aurait beaucoup de changements
et donc je pense que c'est cela qui
était insupportable pour la Russie et
donc ce sont ces valeurs qui sont
combattues et malheureusement il n'y a
pas qu'en Russie cette confrontation
civilisationnelle dont on parle la
France doit s'impliquer comment à quel
niveau alors on a entendu un président
de la Rada réclamé des avions des avions
modernes pour l'instant le président
Macron lui répond par un ré-est exclu
qui est assez évasif à dire vrai où
doit-on aller
alors il faut être assez clair sur cette
histoire parce que une guerre comme ça
c'est pas un magasin de jouets c'est pas
l'addition de toute une série de
matériel car envoyer des avions c'est
pas c'est très compliqué il faut que les
équipes il faut des équipes logistiques
pour l'entretien c'est le même
raisonnement pour les chats en vérité je
pense que les
Ukrainiens lance un message plutôt pour
acquérir pour avoir des F-16 qui sont en
très grand nombre en Europe car le fait
d'avoir de petits contingents d'avion
très différents ne règlerait pas le
problème et en poserait beaucoup plus il
faut quand même former un pilote sur
rafale ou un pilote sur Mirage ça ne se
forme pas en huit jours donc je pense
que
l'attente des Ukrainiens de ce que nous
en savons c'est plutôt sur les
dispositifs de défense entière de
défense aérienne qui vise à combattre
les missiles qui font beaucoup de dégâts
qui tuent beaucoup de personnes civiles
et là je pense que la France peut
effectivement prendre des initiatives on
en a déjà on a déjà un dispositif et je
pense qu'on peut aller plus loin alors
maintenant la décision du Président de
la République
effectivement il peut on peut prendre
une décision qui consisterait non pas à
me semble-t-il à envoyer des rafales
mais peut-être des mirages ou des choses
comme ça mais je ne suis absolument pas
persuadé compte tenu des renseignements
que j'ai que c'est véritablement ce qui
aiderait dans l'immédiat face peut-être
à une offensive de printemps de la
Russie je pense pas que c'est ce qui
aiderait en revanche il faut que la
France montre son soutien comme elle l'a
montré sur l'affaire des chars si vous
regardez les choses c'est le fait que la
France ait décidé d'envoyer des des
chars à MX qui comme par hasard a
déclenché d'autres pays qui
tergiversaient qui étaient plus
réticents alors il faut manifester notre
soutien à la mesure et à la hauteur de
nos de nos capacités de nos moyens on va
vous l'avez vu envoyer plusieurs canons
César supplémentaires 8 qui vont être
acquis sur la base du du fond de 200
millions qu'on a mis à la disposition de
l'Ukraine donc sera 30 30 canons de
César c'est beaucoup des des canons mais
des chats on en reste là pour l'instant
les chats il y en aura c'est le même
raisonnement si vous voulez que pour
l'aviation un char Leclerc c'est pour le
servir c'est 20 personnes tout autour il
faut aller très vite car c'est en ce
moment que l'Ukraine a besoin de ses
matériels et je pense que les chariots
qui sont en beaucoup plus grand nombre
près de 2000 existent en Europe si l'on
prend chaque pays qui est et qui peut
être potentiellement déodateur je pense
qu'il faut être cohérent si vous voulez
encore une fois l'addition de différents
matériels risquerait de poser plus de
problèmes que de résoudre des
difficultés
l'Allemagne la Pologne les États-Unis
sont claires sur leur livraison ou non
de char d'avion ils ont des positions
claires la France elle entretient le
flou Julien le rappelait sur les chars
Leclerc sur les avions Emmanuel Macron
dit rien n'est exclu par principe est-ce
que c'est un problème que la France
n'est pas de message clair
je pense oui enfin je pense que
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de position claire
c'est ça laisse une impression
effectivement
qui n'est pas très qui n'est pas très
agréable et pas très perceptible je
pense par ailleurs que il serait quand
même temps que le Parlement puissant
débattre j'ai vu que des collègues
députés demandaient un débat dans ce
domaine là encore oui ce sont des je
respecte tout à fait les décisions du
président de la République
constitutionnellement il n'est pas il
n'est pas en difficulté puisque c'est
lui le chef des armées donc c'est lui
qui prend un certain nombre de décision
mais je vois que nous sommes à un moment
où dans l'opinion il peut y avoir un peu
de flottement
j'entends qu'effectivement les gens qui
voient cette crise qui ne se termine pas
il y a pas du tout de négociation qui se
nous actuellement et donc le Parlement
est quand même l'interface entre le
gouvernement et l'opinion publique
moi j'ai beaucoup de questions
dans les prochains jours c'est pas la
peine de renvoyer ça dans 6 mois je
pense que ce serait utile d'avoir il
faut accepter d'avoir cette pratique de
débat devant le Parlement ça permet
d'éclairer le sujet et ça permet au
parlementaire de mieux comprendre
l'action du gouvernement et peut-être le
gouvernement d'entendre nos propres
messages comment vous l'expliquez ce fou
parce que par exemple sur les chars
Leclerc l'Allemagne a donné sa décision
sur les chats
elle a mis le temps aussi à le donner
leur décision à date de plus d'une
semaine quand l'Allemagne a parlé la
France a dit on donnera notre décision
dans les prochains jours on la connaît
toujours pas comment vous expliquer ça
parce qu'encore une fois je pense qu'il
y a des contacts au plus haut niveau
entre l'Ukraine et la France pour savoir
si le char Leclerc est véritablement ce
qu'ils font et vraiment pertinent aussi
bien les amis
ça marche c'est très facile de pour les
manier on en avait en stock un char
Leclerc c'est un outil qui est compliqué
qui est sophistiqué qui nécessite tout
autour de lui une équipe logistique or
nos propres soldats qui vont aller en
Ukraine l'entretenir et accessoirement
on en a peu voilà merci de le rappeler
vous parliez d'éclairer le débat c'est
important ce mot parce que il existe
tout un débat autour de la cobellie
gérance est-ce que vous pensez que par
la livraison de ces armes les amis par
exemple dont on parlait on entre dans
une phase de cobelligérance avec avec
l'Ukraine et la Russie je ne pense pas
je pense que l'on fournit on fournit du
matériel si l'Ukraine avait du reste les
ressources nécessaires ils auraient pu
l'acheter c'est ce qu'ils appellent le
commerce des armes c'est les industries
de défense qui répond pour l'instant je
ne considère pour moi le critère c'est
la présence de soldats d'hommes sur le
territoire il n'y en a pas il n'y en a
pas duré ça nous a jamais été reprochés
par la Russie donc on fournit des armes
ils auraient pu les acheter il se trouve
qu'on les fournit parce qu'on considère
que l'Ukraine a fait l'objet d'une
agression faut quand même rappeler ce
principe parce que de temps à autre on
finit par parler de la guerre entre la
Russie et l'U non c'est l'agression de
la Russie contre l'Ukraine qui était un
pays souverain
diplomatieuse parce que vous parlez de
l'escalade et Julien pesait la question
là-dessus de la diplomatie Russie
qu'Emmanuel Macron puisse dire que les
livraisons d'armes ne constituent pas
une escalade qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez et est-ce que vous craignez la
réaction de la réussite ecoutez à chaque
fois on craint la réaction de la Russie
puis il se passe pas grand chose donc
personnellement je pense que ça fait
partie de des échanges verbaux habituels
dans ces temps de très grande tension
c'est vrai que
la la violence avec laquelle la Russie
fait porter ses attaques contre
l'Ukraine nécessite que l'on a l'Ukraine
imaginez que l'Ukraine percée de guerre
ou ça s'arrêtera ou cela s'arrêtera on a
déjà eu quand même beaucoup d'exemples
par le passé d'avancer de de la Russie
moi je garde toujours des inquiétudes
pour les pays baltes pour la Pologne
pour la Roumanie pour la Moldavie qui
est un pays sans armée et sur lequel il
pourrait y avoir une agression russe
donc il faut être solidaire de tous ces
pays mais je crois qu'il y a un moment
où il faut vraiment que l'Occident dise
là la ligne rouge ne peut pas être
dépassée et si elle est dépassée il faut
véritablement que puisse donner les
moyens à l'Ukraine de intervenir
monsieur comment vous avez vu donc le
président de la Rada est-ce qu'il est
très inquiet par rapport à une offensive
de printemps est-ce qu'on doit la
crainte même au niveau européen on a
l'impression que la vaste offensive
risque vraiment d'être marquante et
renseignements que nous avons les sa
pensée que il y a une concentration de
trou plutôt autour de la Crimée parce
que je pense que la Crimée y compris
dans des négociations futures fera
l'objet d'un traitement particulier et
donc c'est plutôt autour des apportsidja
mais
tous les renseignements méritent d'être
rassemblés mais
ce n'est peut-être pas la gigantesque
offensive de printemps avec 500 000
hommes ou que l'on craint ce que l'on
sait c'est que la Russie se prépare
évidemment à vouloir frapper un grand
coup dès que la saison d'hiver va passer
de la part de l'Ukraine d'armes montre
que l'Ukraine est en mauvaise posture
sur le plan militaire disons que pour
l'instant la se passe dans laquelle
l'Ukraine remportait des victoires très
symboliques et très fortes et et pendant
tout le temps où nous avons compris que
l'armée russe n'était pas aussi
puissante était cette phase c'est
j'allais dire plutôt stabilisée on est
dans une guerre de position on voit
autour de village backmouth etc des
combats d'une extrême violence qui
conduise à la destruction de ville et de
village on voit que la Russie est
capable d'utiliser tous les moyens alors
que c'était quand même une puissance
membre du Conseil de sécurité qui avait
adhéré à des grandes chartes
internationales et on voit que
malheureusement les méthodes qui sont
utilisées sont des méthodes terribles
peut-être dernière question sur ce sur
ce sujet de l'Ukraine le président de la
Rada a été à demander d'autres d'autres
sanctions internationales vis-à-vis de
la Russie notamment l'exclusion de toute
compétition internationale est-ce que
vous aussi vous militez pour que la
Russie soit exclue des JO 2024
je pense qu'il y a une certaine logique
en tous les cas à ce que la question
soit posée
vous verrez du reste je reviens à
l'instant sur la première partie de
votre question vous allez vous allez
voir que la semaine prochaine nous
allons délibérer d'une résolution sur
l'Ukraine et que dans cette résolution
il y a une partie très importante qui
demande qu'à la suite de ce conflit y
est une justice car on ne peut pas sous
prêter qu'il y aura un jour négociation
il avait écouté on oublie tout
finalement c'était pas si grave et je
pense qu'il faudra que celles et ceux
notamment qui ont créé cette cette crise
absolument effroyable puisse en répondre
devant la justice internationale alors
après tout autour de cela vous pensez
qu'un jour vous Vladimir Poutine sera
jugé devant un tribunal international
écouter je pense qu'il faut le souhaiter
parce que on ne peut si on continue
comme ça on va retomber dans le monde
d'avant 1914 c'est-à-dire celui où les
grandes puissances utilisaient la force
et la violence pour s'accaparer des pays
voisins on
je pense qu'il y a eu
une
incompréhension peut-être de la part des
autorités burkinabè et il y a une très
forte pression là aussi de la Russie par
l'intermédiaire des ministres Wagner qui
sont qui sont aux commandes et donc
c'est en train de prendre la main sur le
sel bien sûr on a on le sait depuis le
depuis le Mali et maintenant
les pays voisins certains pays voisins
qui ont peut-être à leur tête des
dirigeants qui restent un peu sous
influence de de la Russie prennent ces
décisions c'est effectivement tout à
fait dommageable quand on sait ce que
l'on a pu faire pour ces pays les
soldats français sont morts quand même
pour défendre pour défendre bien sûr
bien sûr et cette force d'action
spéciale qui était stationnée au Burkina
visait plutôt du reste à assurer de la
paix car sans paye il y a pas de
développement donc je crois qu'elle
n'était pas du tout dans un dans un
d'influence sur les dirigeants elle
était là au contraire pour aider dans ce
continent très instable à maintenir la
stabilité et la paix
c'est un échec disons-le bien sûr que
c'est un échec et je pense que là aussi
il va falloir que on procède au fond à
une réflexion sur le rôle de la France
en Afrique
il y a peut-être un certain je pense
personnellement que dans l'affaire du
Mali nous sommes peut-être restés trop
longtemps vous savez il y avait un
général qui était venu devant la
commission des affaires étrangères et
qui avait dit les opérations extérieures
c'est comme les autoroutes tout le
problème est de savoir quelle sortie
vous devez prendre et donc c'est un tout
petit peu ça et je pense qu'au boutique
parce que la sortie n'a pas su être
gérée par les présidents de la
République si vous voulez c'est un
phénomène qu'on a connu de tout temps et
dans de nombreux pays il vous arrivez
comme des libérateurs vous partez comme
des occupants parce que au bout de 8 ans
quelle image fait finalement donné ton
dans les villages que l'on libérait on
voyait des soldats français un peu comme
Robocop qui patrouillait et on a
peut-être pas su me semble-t-il ajouter
à cela le volet développement
c'est-à-dire que si tôt que les villages
et les régions étaient pacifiés il lui
fallut aider à rouvrir les écoles à
rouvrir les centres de santé à faciliter
la vie sur place et donc comme tout ceci
n'a peut-être pas été fait comme nous le
comme nous aurions pu le faire et mais
je pense que le radicalisme est venu par
dessus et apporte une autre une autre
solution et malheureusement ces
dirigeants se laissant porter par les
mirages de des milices Wagner et je
pense qu'il y aura il y aura beaucoup de
difficultés à par la suite monsieur
gourmand il y a une autre région qui
attire les faits médiatiques c'est
l'Arménie il y a une tribune qui a été
publiée mardi dans le monde un collectif
de plus de 160 universitaires et experts
membres de la société savante arménienne
qui dénonce je cite un prélude de
génocide dans le haut Karaba ils
appellent à une intervention humanitaire
de la communauté internationale avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard est-ce que la
situation vous inquiète alors la
situation est très inquiétante
j'ai eu l'occasion il y a 36 heures de
recevoir la nouvelle ambassadrice
d'Azerbaïdjan à Paris et je lui ai dit
très clairement je lui ai rappelé la
position de la France qui est une
position unanimement partagée à savoir
que déjà il faut lever ce blocus sur le
couloir de la Chine de la Chine qui fait
que les Arméniens qui vivent
actuellement dans le en Arsac sur le
haut Karaba sont dans une situation
humanitaire extrêmement préoccupante et
moi j'ai redis la position de la France
à savoir que tant que ce blocus ne
serait pas levé il ne pouvait pas y
avoir d'évolution car l'Azerbaïdjan se
plaint beaucoup de son image en France
et en Occident mais à la fois les
déclarations du président alayif qui
était comme assez violentes contre les
Arméniens doivent être
doivent être condamnés il faut
véritablement c'est la solution elle ne
peut intervenir contre ces deux pays et
il y a un troisième acteur qui manque
beaucoup ce sont les Russes ils étaient
ils étaient les garants de l'accord de
ces éleveux or les Russes pour des
raisons que l'on a bien d'évoquer à
savoir que les troupes qu'il consacrait
à la pacification de cette partie du
monde il les emploie contre les
ukrainiens et donc
l'Azerbaïdjan est un petit peu
laisser à lui-même et je crois
qu'effectivement la France doit parler
haut et fort nous le faisons nous avons
pris plusieurs résolutions j'ai été
rapporté de l'une d'entre elles et je
crois qu'il faut que l'Occident soit
très attentif à ce qui se passe dans
cette partie de la France doit parler au
effort dites-vous mais c'est est-ce
qu'elle doit aller par exemple jusqu'à
un soutenir officiellement la demande de
l'Arménie d'une action en cours
internationale de justice pour prononcer
des mesures ordonnant à l'Azerbaïdjan de
libérer ce couloir je pense que les
Nations Unies doivent être doivent faire
leur travail je pense en revanche que
nous devrions faire nous-mêmes c'est
pouvoir doter de manière plus efficace
l'Arménie d'armes défensive notamment de
fournitures de radars etc pour au moins
qu'ils puissent s'organiser vous savez
c'est un pays qui n'est pas si fort que
cela et qu'il faut véritablement
soutenir on peut tout à fait je crois
qu'on va commencer à le faire
doté ce pays d'un certain nombre
défensives de telle sorte de lui donner
les moyens de se défendre face à ce qui
peut apparaître effectivement comme
c'est un sujet très complexe qui va
chercher ses racines dans l'histoire
donc ce ne sont pas des déclarations à
l'emporte-pièce de tel ou telle
dirigeant qui régleront les choses je
pense qu'il faut conduire l'Azerbaïdjan
et la et l'Arménie autour de la tête du
discussion il y a un acteur qui est par
derrière très important et nous ne
cessons de leur dire c'est la Turquie
car la Turquie
voilà et la Turquie veut jouer un rôle
de puissance régionale dans cette région
il faut lui demander aussi de prendre
ses responsabilités qui doivent être de
conduire ces pays vers la paix et non
pas vers les tensions perpétuelles on va
passer à l'actualité du Sénat hier les
sénateurs qui ont voté l'inscription de
l'IVG dans la Constitution pourtant la
droite la majorité n'y était pas
favorable et pourtant c'est tout le tour
d'un amendement du sénateur les
républicains Philippe Bas que s'est fait
le consensus pourquoi se revirement de
la droite sénatoriale alors il faut
ramener les choses à leur juste
proportion
d'abord d'où vient cette affaire cette
affaire vient de manière assez étrange
du fait que un certain nombre d'États
américains ont remis en cause le droit à
l'avortement en France je ne sache pas
que ce droit est jamais été remis en
cause il a pu parfois y avoir des
médecins qui résistaient c'est un autre
sujet mais le droit
en la matière est très clair moi je suis
un
je suis fer de manière fervente
favorable à l'application de la loi
veille qui a pu véritablement offrir une
avancée aux femmes françaises qui
étaient en grande difficulté je ne vois
pas au jour d'aujourd'hui j'étais mère
pendant 28 ans je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui les difficultés qu'il y a à
mettre en oeuvre la loi la loi veille
sur le territoire national alors fort de
ce qui s'est passé aux États-Unis un
pays la France a voulu montrer qu'on
était capable d'en faire plus que les
autres et donc il y a eu cette
initiative de Madame panot d'un certain
nombre de parlementaires de
et même de Mélanie Vogel qui vous a
précédé sur ce plateau
bon pour des raisons politiques tout à
fait évidentes c'est tout à fait leur
droit et chaque parlementaire peut
prendre ce genre d'initiative moi
personnellement je ne considère pas que
ce droit doit être présent dans la
Constitution française parce que on
ouvre une boîte de Pandore vous avez il
y a de nombreux droits qui à partir de
ce moment-là vont remplir la concession
ce n'est pas le rôle de la constitution
de déposer
j'ai compris sans tout à fait comprendre
je comprends que dans l'intention de
Philippe Bas il y a le fait de ne pas
arrêter la procédure parlementaire
puisque du fait de ce vote je vais faire
un peu de constitutionnel l'espace d'un
instant à partir du moment où les textes
ne sont pas identiques en matière de loi
constitutionnelle il faut que la navette
ait lieu puisque une loi
constitutionnelle ne peut être votée que
dans les mêmes termes par l'Assemblée
nationale et par le Sénat en faisant
voter un amendement par le Sénat le
texte va revenir à l'Assemblée donc le
débat continue mais ça ne veut pas dire
pour autant contrairement à ce qui est
dit un petit peu dans la presse ici ou
là aujourd'hui ça veut pas dire que le
droit à l'IVG est inscrit dans la
Constitution car il faut que cette
navette est lieu il faut que les deux
textes soient voter de matière identique
par les deux assemblées dans
l'amendement et accessoirement en
application de l'article 89 de la
Constitution il faut que le Président de
la République déclenche un référendum
j'attends de voir oui mais est-ce que
tout se débalade empêche niustre pas une
forme de division au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale est-ce qu'il y a pas un coin
qui est mis dans cette différence
d'appréciation vous savez ça existe dans
un groupe d'une telle importance
Philippe Bas était très proche de Simone
Veil il a il a été du reste ministre
d'affaires sociales bon il a peut-être
une vision qui est un petit peu
différente moi personnellement encore
une fois je suis absolument pour que les
femmes puissent disposer de la liberté
de leur corps pour l'application de la
loi veille mais je ne pense pas que ce
droit plus qu'un autre très vite d'être
dans la Constitution parce qu'il n'est
pas en danger il n'a jamais été en
danger depuis le vote de la loi veille
et donc je pense qu'on ouvre là des
perspectives qui pourraient être
dangereuses pour d'autres pour d'autres
sujets merci Christian Cambon merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
regarde la Une de La Voix du Nord
arnaque à la prime énergie ils doivent
rembourser 4000
de cette de cette arnaque aujourd'hui
dans la voie du Nord merci Julien écuyer
merci Christian